THCH FOR YOUR TIME
KATICHY.
OREMARKS AT HIS HFTINMcCONNELLN
REGULARLY SCHEDULED CE.>> AFTE
,
TOSS>> LET'S GO D, JINS RAJ ONO
NED.D TOIM ABOUT THANG MOMENT TM
E.ERHIS ,
THEN HE LATER RETURNED AND UT
E.
WHEN I A WHETHERCOULD , HEHE.LDR
SUFFERED A CONCUSSION?
JOB?eporteOW McCONNELL
FIVENS OR SO ON ISSUES MT FELTEA
CHNT
SUSTAINED TUTO RAS OUTNATERETUR.
RSKSASAD T LL ONEN ABOU.A COUP S
WEREARLE, THE
QUESTIONS WEREERDITHAR
AN ANOTHER SITUATION THAT'RATIOL
NOT GOING ANYWHERETHAST END OFH.
HE'S UP FO AGAIN
HE HASOT MY ANUNE LEADER
NOTICE NEXR WHETHER N  ATHIS WI
WATO TO
F WONDER AS R THI
30-SOMS TH TG UP STRUCK
YO SIGNIFICA?
HAT WACONCERNINGTHERE'K HE'SED
PROBABLY LK AT THAT CLIP
TO TRY ANDT
WHAT EXACTLY HAPPENETHERE.
S THATOMTO T
MIND BUTCORRECTLY POINT OUT, JI
DEATIDALRE SERUSAS TT MASEIZUREN
PESK T.WAS JUST AT THE
DS HE WA
ONE ASKED IF HE WAS OKAYS  W WA.
WHEN HE WALKED OFF WAS
VILEGSD SIGN THAT
HAD HAEN SLIKE IT D TOMIR
ASKED HI ESTION AND HING OKAYBU
THU VEAS COMMOT OFLL, BUT  HAVE
EEDS A FE BUT HE NEEDS
TO GET CHECK CLEARLY ASKU IF H
IMMEDI AND TO
KNOWLEDG D
WHENHIIN OLDER ACRONYM, BE FAST
BALANCE, EYE MOVEMENKEY HAA
ASSESSNTIF AOR PATIEEXHIU
IMPORTANT.'T OVERSTATE
EARLY F  T.
R IT WASCAE N OR
SOMETHINLI
2REKEAY32 S
LECTHE WAS IT D IT APPEARED
HE HAD STRENGTAN
RIGHT F